what's the first big purchase if you
were a billionaire like what's a let's
say you just from today until tomorrow
all of a sudden boom bobby you're a
billionaire we don't know why what is
your first massive purchase i know what
you would do i don't think you do you'd
buy the comedy store
oh no i wouldn't oh i thought you or
you'd buy almost every billboard on like
hollywood
and put fake shows that you're in that's
funny because that's that that would i
never thought of that but that would be
think about the whole like that's like
80 billboards
devlin's nightmare
but it's like holding a gun devlin's
nightmare right and i'm like in a
[ __ ] like warlock you know what i
mean all your friends are gonna be like
on sunset boulevard like what the [ __ ]
he's in everything yeah yeah he's on
every single that's a good
yeah sunji's choice
i wear a kimono right i'm wearing kimono
right and jimmy yang is wearing kimono
right oh he's and she he's like on my
chest and i'm just doing sunji's choice
right
and then what else movies could we do no
just do like
let me see
some of them shouldn't even have titles
they're just backlog back lot
manifesto
was that about i don't know but it's
like it's us us five four s4 we're in
suits
and we all have like this funny like
anonymous mess but it's our like mind
mask right and we have briefcases and
we're just like
yeah
back luck man backlot manifesto
apple tv it's not even coming out
yeah right they have to sue us but we
have the money we can do this now what
what wait why don't it only cost 750 we
can set some money aside and put one
right in front of which one
750 a month wait i want to go back to
the titles of your mixtape maybe one of
them can be a title for your 750 a month
dude we can do this no but i'll tell you
why you can't because like the ones that
are on sunset are like you could you can
tell that those ones might be the 15 000
ones and also they're also um
don't the networks have like oh they own
they own it or they have like uh
leasing you know what i mean option i
don't know okay here i have the the
movies this is supposed to be on your
your your mixtape okay remember yeah
yeah save the pelicans
that me tom hanks yeah sandra bullock
we'll just do old hollywood you know
yeah i like that and it's us we're on an
island
right
and the poster is
you know i mean
tom hanks and sandra they sandra bullock
they're wearing some sort of like um
you know not um hazmat suits but white
suits has this u.n on it oh you and does
it you wouldn't have anything to do with
it maybe maybe what about this i'm not
done yet oh you're not right yeah and
i'm on a cross
right wow wow right and i get that from
say no i know but the pelicans are
eating
my flesh you know what i mean okay what
about fiddler father urban mother oh
that's a good one what are these hold on
this is
fiddler father
fizzler father urban mother yeah
right i know what it's about what is it
about what it's about is i'm
i have two who are the actors well let
me just tell you the story and i'll tell
you the actors right
it's it's about reincarnation
oh man okay very hindy now so you know i
mean in the
late 1800s right it's a bollywood film
no no no no no i'm an english kid okay
right but i'm gonna play do it with me
but i'll put white makeup on
right and then we'll have honestly white
face we're gonna green screen we're just
screwing in my eyes
so we're gonna go green
you have see
so basically right i'll add white makeup
i'll have
grease so it has that like michael
shannon effect
like a little fish eye yeah yeah in post
right right so it'll be like
we'll do we have the money right so do
it in post right
and hello you know what i mean and i'm
like a son of a fiddler yeah right and
it's like like fiddling on the roof
right but we're just
right right right like that right
right and it cuts to what's the second
one
the urban mother
neck cut two right okay i get
reincarnated right yeah and that um
i'm who's that lady from um
hidden figures oh tasha
tavia
she gives birth reaper and i get reborn
right again black makeup
greek screen green screen screens clean
the eyes right but then but then you put
delroy lindo's or whatever you know what
i mean yeah so it's like two lives right
so do you think that's good that's a
great one one more movie title this
one's a bit of a long one so it might
take a lot of billboard space
those are see those are delroy linda
eyes
oh he's got good eyes yeah yeah all
right so this one's a long one you have
to really consider this one one of your
movie titles is chilongo diaz is my
friend but i don't know him personally
that's just a sentiment
yeah i don't know him personally solango
diaz is my friend but i don't know him
personally yeah
i know what it is
gianlungo diaz right he's the greatest
right
soccer player in south america
right but this is not now
in 60 years from now wow right
and
i am a kid i just play korean okay right
but you still have cgi eyes of course
but make it japanese okay right so it's
like yeah that's good that's good i like
it you're they do you're a producer bro
all right you're giving me great ideas
cgi right so it's like you know how much
it might slander like this yeah it's
gonna be slender like the opposite yeah
the opposite way right so they're gonna
be like wow that's weird right it um it
looks different right yeah so chilongo
diaz right is a soccer player from the
future right
and um what's his skill level like
maradona oh he's better he's
he can do all of it too right he's like
he can go keep
right
in fact in the future right
there's only
they half the team is they don't even
need half the team he does it all he
does it all wow right the midfield he's
the center forward and the goalie
he's just running back he runs back and
forth
he's with his eyes yeah yeah no i'm not
jealous
i'm not chilling oh diaz right i mean
imagine the work right
all right dude all-star all-star right
so he's going back and forth back and
forth right and he's always complaining
too
can you hire more people
i'm tired
right
and i'm a kid a korean kid now right
chilongo diaz ain't even born yet bro
yeah and i'm [ __ ]
at a park right playing soccer with my
kid with my kids okay cool right and
then
there's a lightning storm
slightening lightning a slightly
stronger slight storm it's a slight
storm right that's what i call it right
very good lights learn big lightning
yeah big like
i get zapped right and for some reason i
get zapped right
and
i get connected to chulango in the
future
right so then i know his heart
i know his motivation his work ethic
right so i know him but he's not my i've
never met him
you know what i'm saying i know him so i
don't know
i know him but i don't you know yeah
right and then what this is a great
scene though it's a great scene right
i i'm like a 30 year old guy right
i decided to try out for the [ __ ] um
the la um galaxy galaxy right oh nice i
become the center forward yeah then that
what happens is they go hey dude
we fired everyone
it's just you you're the greatest so i'm
like right
i become a legend right
and then i'm like 60 years old or
whatever
and i go to like
senpai sao paulo
sao paulo to a hospital check this out
this is a great scene
it's a great secret right
you were like what is he doing that the
legendary you know i mean what was
my name is rit toshi
the legendary rick toshi what is he
doing here right and then
i see a baby being born
and it's
too long it's long
right i have a cane
and you see me
look at too long
he's crying right and i look at him and
i just kind of turn around that's the
last shot i walk away damn
oh i thought maybe you were going to
kill him because you don't i thought you
were going to i thought you're going to
kill him
i thought about it yeah yeah but if you
kill him maybe i won't have the vision
later you know earlier right so he must
exist yeah interesting right so that's
that's well i'm fully invested so i'm
not going to move on to the next title
which is dip your dick
but those are pretty good movies that's
what i would do with the billion dollars
but what i would really do
right i'll just tell you what i would
really do
i would buy
a piece of land probably in malibu right
and i would probably i've always wanted
to kind of design my own house oh cool
yeah man and i would do um
i don't know if this is possible but
hear me out i have this fantasy of